why are there more Davids than women managing money
in the UK and around the world?
the data compiled by Morningstar
showed that of 1 500 funds,
Davids outnumbered all women,
followed by Paul's,
James's and nick's.
diversity is a major issue,
with many initiatives looking to address the proportion
of women in senior roles in financial services,
but change is not coming fast enough.
more recently,
MSCI noted a slowdown in the rate
for female representation on boards,
with a gain of only 0.6%
among listed companies.
just 23 companies have majority female boards,
including Kerin,
H amp M and l'oreal,
all fashion proximate companies.
508 companies have all male boards,
including JD com,
Xiaomi and Saudi Telecom.
we have a long way to go before we reach the 30
and 50 targets for women on boards.